this is pretty scary
no no you didn't mess up I just I
couldn't stop laughing
dead kittens what you lookin for
if this fucking device is rich dig I
think it's very faint mine comrade do
you know a James no you know oh I'm a
hungry guy say we were about to defend
ourselves against a group of angry
people
oh my baby is that good enough for you
do you know what I can now do you style
a booth Fabrizio I work here who are you
right did you just believe damn it I
thought you wanted Mountain as well
you're drunk it's okay delicious
- I think here joints kind of racist I
look delicious
that's amazing
you tried that once in prison so Doug do
you want to explain this certainly which
we have here
we got Yahoo the right hand of doom we
have duct tape which isn't very exciting
and a fire extinguisher not particularly
exciting but we have fire West raisin
and that's dead
right yes oh look how big that
schneizel's you could pick it if you
wanted and you have this thing from
20,000 feet and then you also have this
construction amat good god you'll be
needing that and this sword is its
barbra streisand that sells in its I
mean and that's the only way you can
shut up a filthy animal who doesn't
lines and that is how you dispose of a
filthy animal who won't keep his mouth
shut
that was rabbit stool pigeon okay are
you comfortable there you're doing okay
on a leather couch you know me you're be
completely maybe get some more clues
here all right let's see Northern
Virginia Army of Northern Virginia Army
of Northern Virginia Confederates what
is it the Confederates of America I
can't remember that Bon Appetit I know
dad's still for the camera that's okay